hey guys it's Johanna here so I have
been receiving a lot of comments asking
me whether a particular workout will end
up giving you bulky legs well why would
I do that no my exercises will not give
you back your legs instead they would
sleep and tone up your legs what we'll
be doing today is a dance inspired leg
exercises for a lean and long looking
legs well of course if you are petite
like me
you will still maintain the same height
by doing these exercises combined with a
good posture can make your muscles
appear longer so what you'll need is a
chair to support you just like what I
have behind me or you can use a kitchen
counter and do these exercises while
waiting for your food to cook and always
remember to start with a quick 5 to 10
minutes warm up
so we'll be doing 20 repetitions for
each workout and remember that this
chair should only support you so try not
to leave you and tie body weights on the
chair the first workout is ballet top
raises so stand up should with a pot
with it with your toes pointed out and
we just want to be doing 20 car phrases
so ticked oh good three four and really
tighten your core five and engage your
core in order to balance yourself six
good seven and just gently so put your
arm on the chair nine ten as you come up
really squeeze your calf muscle and feel
your calves working three good keep
going four five stand tall six seven
nine eight
can you feel your cuffs working nine ten
and now I want you to stand tiptoe and
we want to go straight into PA squats so
tiptoe and keep it 20 plie squats go all
the way down to keep your body upright
three and you should really feel your
inner thighs working for go low squeeze
five good six seven so imagine you are
doing plie squat with your fuse on eight
nine nine ten
open wide and really figure inner thighs
good one
and your thighs as well two three good
for five last five remember to tighten
your core throw all the work out three
last two to one and stay low and now
give me small ten houses one two three
four five six seven eight nine seven
whew can you feel your eyes burning very
good and now we
to get straight into cross bag lunch so
start with your left leg bring your
right leg up and I'm going to cross over
just like you're doing curtsy lunge and
as you come up squeeze your right butt
okay so go look crossover
work on your left leg up and squeeze
your bike back ready let's do 20 reps on
one side down good up and squeeze
- so when you're low you're working on
your left side when you're up you are
working on your right side three four
squeeze nice five to keep your balance
again engage your core six seven squeeze
nice and control eight squeeze nice
squeeze ten squeeze ten more
one squeeze good - squeeze you should
really feel your eyes working three
squeeze and always imagine that you're
standing tall for by nice 6:07 all the
way up three more eight squeeze nine
squeeze one more ten squeeze good and
now change side so start with your right
side okay right side left leg down one
squeeze the left back to up work with
your right thigh squeeze your left
good three nice four five feet good six
remember to cross over seven eight doing
a good job
nine ten last ten one go low
to try to only support yourself and do
not lean your weight too far forward
three always keep it in the center for
squeeze five plus five cross six seven
eight point nine one more ten very very
good now let's move on to side leg
raises okay so stand tall again and we
just want to start with our right side
so bring your legs in squeeze your inner
thighs and as you bring it up stretch it
as high as you can and really work on
your outer thigh okay so this workout
really works on the inner and outer
thigh right let's get ready and lengthen
your legs
let's go 20 swing one get to keep
yourself centered three nice for nice
and controlled
five so do not just let your leg draw
six up seven eyes and controls eight
nine good ten ten more one two very good
I want to see those long legs 45.6
spent all seven eight last two points
nine last one ten and I'll just shake it
out and we want to get straight into leg
circles so bend in your posture bring
your legs up slightly and give me small
Technic circles one side one two three
point four five six
we squeeze every part of your thighs
eight nine ten reverse one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten so
not only are you working on this side
you will feel the burn on your left
thigh - and I'm going to sweep it over
and let's work on the other side okay
exactly the same move get ready and I'm
up stand tall and let's go swing up line
four good - good
three up on your toes four
so you should really focus on your outer
thighs five nice six seven squeeze the
more you do this the better you will get
eight nine ten ten more let's go one
swing and controlled - I am sweating
three good four five show me those long
legs six seven eight last two nine ten
and we are not resting because we're
getting straight into legs circles so up
ten times forward one squeeze two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
reverse one two three four five six or
seven eight nine and ten and I just
relax and shake your thighs out good job
so perform all five exercises as one set
in to complete three to four sets and
try not to rest more than one minutes in
between sets and always remember to
stretch at
of your workouts stretching is the key
for a long and lean looking muscles and
of course just remind yourself daily to
maintain a good posture and to stand
tall all of us for new fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my youtube channel and
website do follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys
you